es ist der spektakuläre juwelenraub aus
dem grünen gewölbe in dresden der noch
immer nicht aufgeklärt ist doch jetzt
soll es die ersten neun hinweise geben
für die aufklärung und bild hat einmal
für sie zusammengefasst was genau dort
in dresden passiert war
es ist ein kunstraub in milliarden höhe
die gestohlenen schätze sind einmalig
und unbezahlbar dresden
fünfundzwanzigster etwa 2019 zwei
unbekannte täter brechen mit gewalt in
das historische grüne gewölbe 15 weitere
verbrecher sollen an der tat beteiligt
sein
für die behörden ist klar die einbrecher
haben insiderwissen und offenbar hilfe
aus dem museum bekommen denn die täter
kennen sich bestens aus ins visier der
ermittler kommen zwei mitarbeiter des
museums jetzt führen spuren eines
berliner klar milieu bild liegen
informationen von insidern vor das
sächsische fahnder belastbare beweise
gegen den libanesischen arabischen
medien plan haben
es gebe erkenntnisse dass sich ein
großteil der beute bei miri leuten
befinde
unter anderem der wertvolle diamanten
degen soll lokalisiert worden sein
die kriminellen schein unterschätzt zu
haben wie schwer es ist das diebesgut zu
verkaufen
parallel wächst die hoffnung dass die
geklauten kunstgegenstände nicht um
geschliffen oder eingeschmolzen wurden
polizei und staatsanwaltschaft ordnete
die hinweise zu mclaren als spekulation
ein von verbindungen zu mir die klagen
will auch das sächsische
innenministerium nichts wissen es wird
auch keine schwierigkeiten bei den
ermittlungen geben doch auch hier liegen
bild informationen vor dass sich die
berliner und dresdner polizei in die
quere kommen nicht immer scheint klar zu
sein wie die kompetenzen der behörden
verteilt sind und wer welche zeugen
vernehmen darf seit dem dreißigsten
fünften ist das grüne gewölbe wieder
zugänglich und die behörden scheinen
sich auf einen totalverlust der
staatlichen kunstsammlung eingestellt zu
haben
über diese neuen exklusiven erkenntnisse
die bild vorliegen möchte ich nun
sprechen mit jürgen helfrich der
zugeschaltet ist irgendwas genau kannst
du uns sagen was halt bild erfahren
haben dass dresden ich stehe hier vor
dem dresdner residenzschloss genau vor
dem fenster an dem am 25 november in den
frühen morgenstunden unbekannte bislang
unbekannte gangster einen der
spektakulärsten juwelenraub haben
es gibt zwei wichtige neue informationen
der erste ist dass in seite uns
berichtet haben dass die
sonderkommission applet zu der auch drei
staatsanwälte gehören jetzt an heißen
spur nachgehen und zwar dem libanesisch
arabischen amerika an der unter anderem
auch in berlin ansässig ist und die
weitere auch gute information und
neuigkeit dass die klaren angehörigen es
nicht vermochten wohl diese schätze zu
verkaufen und sie auch nicht um
geschliffen haben also es sollen
wirklich ein großteil dieser dinge noch
vorhanden seien unter anderem dieser
tier gegen mit über 700 brillanten das
war bisher nicht vermutet worden denn in
seite oder auch experten wie
auktionshäuser hatten uns mitgeteilt
dass dieser schatz der etwa an wert der
geschätzt wird bis zu einer halben
milliarde euro
ganz schnell ungeschliffen wird und kaum
in gänze in fremde hände gelangen könnte
er ist gerade gesagt hier unfassbar
wertvoll dieser schatz ist welche
bedeutung welche auswirkungen hatte
dieser juwelenraub also auf dresden
also mit dem juwelenraub hat man quasi
ins herz der kultur und der identität
der sachsen gegriffen die kronjuwelen
waren ja nicht nur für die sächsischen
kurfürsten und könige die bis 1918
regiert haben ein wichtiges wichtige
repräsentations gegenstand sondern sie
waren auch immer staatsschatz also man
hat diese juwelen in kriegszeiten zum
beispiel auf die festung königstein
gerettet und hat sie besonders geschützt
ist aber eine extra wacht kompanie nach
dem ende der monarchie 1908
würden sie weiterhin diesem grünen
gewölbe verwahrt und das war natürlich
eine tiefe demütigung dass es
verbrechern gelang in so kurzer zeit
sich ein großteil dieses staates habhaft
zu machen
umso mehr ist es jetzt wichtig dass so
schnell wie möglich dieses verbrechen
aufgeklärt wird und möglichst ein
großteil dieser wertvollsten
kunstschätze zurück nach sachsen kommt
wir können gespannt sein was sich da in
den nächsten wochen und monaten tut